とある方からツイッターでいただきました始め組んだら目を瞑ってても全て完璧に
当てろれることを願っている
を
なるほど助けにここにある飲み物ってあの全部言い方悪くすると
一緒なんですよもちろん違いますよ分かってます違うと味は全然違うんですただあ
やっぱ乳製品というカテゴリーたとなんかなんて中野北味音痴みたいな人間からそれで
ばあちゃん全貌だぞように感じちゃうんである今ちょっとヘがバレるような言い方をし
てしまったんですけどまぁかろうじて味は全く一緒です
こんにちははじめしゃちょーねそういうわけで
とよりで new 的に買ってきましたまずビックル
よく見ますねまぁにおいしいみールージュ
はいはいみますねーキールくる俺もあるリックル
パブっと芸ビューニーロがつよいぞ微妙に違うなあこっちはビッグる500に対して
こっちは6ズレしのビッグですね
そしても乳製品って言ったらこれでしょうヤクルト
本当は google ととかも入れたかったんですけどもあの日の住んでる地域には
これくらいしかちょっとありませんでした
twitter でいただいて通りなんですけどもこれ見分けられたら
結構マジですごいと思うんですよだってもう見てどれ見てもさ乳酸菌ということが入っ
てるんですよ
乳酸菌乳酸菌乳酸菌乳酸菌乳酸菌乳亭品で同じコンセプトで作られてるんで日本的に味
の構図的には一緒だと思うんですよあとは微妙な違いとか
でもなぜか僕はマミーが一番おいしいかなって思ってしまいます味見してみましょう
まずびっくりから飲んでみますえっ
発で覚えられたら一番いいですね
罰踏めあちの最後にずっと隠さ要素が絶甲苦味がホロってあるような気がしますはから
ね素敵とですよねそれでまみいきます
あー薄いまビッグるど比べてかなり汗が薄めだと思いましたぞ edm ジェシー
big big 500担任が違う国には分からぬなと
おっ
なんか変なんか見るきって感じです甘いキャベツですから見る聞いてかつ続いて3
ルートですあああカールぴずに近いなぁカルピ炭を感じれば多分ミル子だと思います
つづくふけるくるですてかもう名前など劣化が覚えられないんだよ
特徴が無い国で若干最初に苦味がきい増田最後ヤクルト飲んでみます
[音楽]
ています
うわぁや genten ゲンテンって感じですね特に母触れません
マジで本当にないねで1台はかんだよはいというわけでだいたい味は覚えました
まずでこれ当てたら僕のことを込めてくださいヒョッそれでもいいんで
少量入れて渡していければ z やってるよ
よろしくお願いますヤクルトとかたぶん朝が飛んでわかるところでちょっと声出して
ます
a
rumor
today
ふーん
きましたねはいではくださいはい
[音楽]
止めました
私が今飲んだのは
マミです
the ねー
可能貸さず2nd セカンドオピニオン
よく僕には静観 ob に用があるんです
私はなどがピークです
[音楽]
世界は前お客様まあまあ最初はばいよいよすよ
こんなんで混ぜて負けないじゃないですかあとにはいっすよ本当にびっくりさ
シュッ
ten ten
脚力を
あよし
では
ください
[音楽]
あわかったはいはいはいはい私はから3パットに来る子の種が間違いない私が今飲んだ
のは
big 500です
the ねー
セカンドオピニオンくださいはいそれかねぇ
私が今飲んだのでん
はいいやくるとですね私が今飲んだのは
ヤクルトです the ねえ
正解はマミですもういくらテキサスくださいやばいよ阿呆でこんなに外した方がない
ですよ僕このタイプの f
それにいつもはなんかの兄さんは後れずに必ず
一切外せばということでございません
p 4
とかパナマお願いします
はい肌になろうなど
そりゃあもうやっ
いっぱいの帰国薄めだった気がすんだよな薄い徹底誘うマミカミルズっぽい気も済んだ
よ私が今飲んだのは
みる樹です
坐禅ビショだ
[音楽]
me
me あった